[Music]
will will announce anchorman three and I
want to announce tonight wins world
three yeah it's it's a puppet show we're
doing it's a mall tool anyway waiting
garthen middle-aged you know wait wait
when I go I want to go swing that I go
swing you didn't buy every staff hi Mike
[Applause]
celebration this is great this is how it
should be well that's right George
senior he endorsed Mitt Romney today oh
that's why I heard that was gonna happen
yeah well gotta say he's the one the
others were a little nutty
he's a Mormon got kind of funny belief
system some kind sometimes kind of steps
in it says he doesn't care about poor
people bad I'm out here you have so many
instantly recognizable impressions but I
want to pay you a compliment which is
that every person including myself who
doesn't Arnold Schwarzenegger impression
we all learned it from you we all got it
from you you were the first time yeah
you nailed it what happened was all
right yeah what it is is I'm not a very
good impressionist and I get bored and
we have this symbiotic thing where we
like to take things take liberties and
take things very far
stretch it out yeah can I get a little
Arnold just well my Arnall if you're
right you just start right and then I'm
eating a sausage sausage yeah you can do
different things with him I think that
the thing about Arnold and all these
things over there and all the people and
the things is that you can state obvious
things and find it mesmerizing like he
would I'd say oh how is Colin yeah you
go on the Conan show you see did the
chair and Colin Colin is talking and
Andy over the lobby negative
[Applause]
like a magical journey he takes you home
now suddenly I'm 37
hey but you know I'm sunny which is that
you've got to have a take on this Arnold
just kind of disappeared he had this it
came out that he had this the Sun that
he had had with his housekeeper and
you'd think for comedian and for someone
like you who does such a great Arnold
this would be amazing but where is he
right now I haven't heard like our I
hope he gets back together but he if
anyone can charm his way back together
with yeah yeah because he just has this
very charming you know I saw the
housekeeper and I had made the baby with
the housekeeper because the cows keeper
you know had the big metatarsals in they
did the neck the products were round the
most Kyra so I wanted to make one super
muscle baby for the world you want to go
out to to all sorts and something get
little fishes are they together we could
do together
yeah I'm doing like a puppy dog oranges
I did a press conference with him once
this has restaurants with the real yeah
and they were mad they're like what's he
doing up here he was down the Gandhi and
he explained you would love this the
comedian and they're really angry and
they're screaming you suck and he'd they
go the deficit grew so big goes yeah
yeah I did up you know this is when he
was governor
unemployment yeah I made this huge
amonges you know and then we get off and
they're just the press cores you're a
racist you're an idiot you know and we
got off stage ago Jesus they're always
like that and he said quote with this
big cigar he goes yeah the matter they
get the cooler I get
[Applause]
was an F word I used because it was
actually part of that door including you
recording the world's figure so when we
come back when we come you so in Piers
Morgan now when we come back I want to
out when people say that you're stupid
does that bother you is that looks a
very good first Morgan is that what he
does well he flatters you're really
great everyone loves your album you're
really fantastic but when we come back
oh I want to know what it's like that
people think you're moronic does that
bother you it's a new one six o'clock
after Larry King I'm not gonna swear
anymore but this is though you bet I
know you'll be doing it